this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skill share learn to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking the link in the description
schadenfreude a' is defined as pleasure
derived from another person's misfortune
but it should also be defined as
watching a bunch of entitled rich
parents get indicted for fraudulently
trying to get their stupid kids into
college so can I get some 90s sitcom
music
[Music]
whatever happened to meritocracy the
class rank the GPA even SAT
[Music]
[Music]
we wear a white face
[Music]
hey legal eagles today we're talking
about the college admissions scandal
we're gonna mix things up a little bit
because this story has everything the
rich and famous lots of bad things
happening to bad people and RICO
violations so today we're gonna talk
about the allegations in the indictment
and we're also going to talk about what
it means to have a Rico prosecution so
here's the background 50 people
including full house actress Lori
Loughlin aka Aunt Becky and actress
Felicity Huffman are facing federal RICO
charges for allegedly participating in
an elaborate bribery scheme to get their
children into elite universities there
are a lot of rich and famous people here
but most people know about Lori Loughlin
from Full House so I'm going to refer to
defendants collectively as Aunt Becky in
this case the kingpin if you will
William singer created a company called
the edge college and career Network LLC
also known as the key ostensibly as a
for-profit college counseling and
preparation business he also started the
key worldwide foundation or k WF as a
501 C 3 non-profit for similar purposes
the government's indictment alleges that
singer engaged in rampant racketeering
or fraud that falls into three buckets
first the indictment alleges that singer
facilitated cheating on the AC T and SAT
exams in exchange for bribes number two
it alleges that he designated applicants
as purported recruits for competitive
college athletic teams without regard to
whether the student had actually
participated in athletics at all and
number three concealing the nature and
source of these bribery payments by
funneling the payments through the k WF
Charitable Foundation account so let's
talk about the first type of fraud and
racketeering that's alleged in the
indictment the government's indictment
alleges that to facilitate the cheating
singer counseled Aunt Becky to seek
extended time on her kids exams by
having doctors falsely state that her
children had learning disabilities in
order to obtain the medical
documentation required for the College
Board to grant extra time on the
standardized tests you
additionally the indictment states that
in exchange for bribery payments
co-conspirators allowed aunt Becky's
kids to secretly take the a CT and SAT
tests in special rooms where they were
given more time or the children's
responses were actually replaced with
the correct answers if your children are
accepted here you won't be expected to
work with them at home rather
intensively so that they may reap the
optimum benefits from our curriculum
oh yeah well our kids love to reap the
second type of fraud Aunt Becky paid
singer approximately twenty five million
dollars over the course of 2011 through
2019 to bribe coaches and university
administrators to designate her children
as recruited athletes or other favored
admissions categories to jump the line
into college we may have well he may
have embellished lied a bit on our
application honesty kick away oh my god
you guys the Skillshare plug at the end
of this video is going to be so epic
Aunt Becky often photoshopped fake
photos of her kids on to other athletes
to make the fraud seem more believable
and given that Aunt Becky lives in LA a
lot of the fraud concerned LA colleges
as a UCLA grad myself it gives me no
pleasure to point out that this scandal
appears to permeate through the entire
University of Southern California
resulting in multiple coaches at USC
being fired it gives me no pleasure at
all to point that out
none at all none and I have no idea why
people often refer to USC as the
University of spoiled children oh my god
i'ma get in trouble for that but it's
worth it but that takes me to the third
type of fraud of course most or all of
these bribery payments were labeled as
charitable contributions so essentially
these million-dollar bribes were
subsidized by the federal government and
correspondences singers sent to Aunt
Becky in response to a purported
charitable contribution to kW f of two
hundred and fifty one thousand dollars
singer stated that your generosity will
allow us to move forward with our plans
to provide educational and self
enrichment program
to disadvantaged youth so to summarize
Aunt Becky spent millions of dollars on
bribes and fraudulent payments to get
her kids into college got to write all
of that amount off as a charitable
deduction which effectively cuts the
cost in half subsidized by other
taxpayers and got a letter saying that
she was helping disadvantaged youth you
want class rights because this is how
you get class riots by the way it's
worth noting that all of this got
started because one of the participants
wanted to get a lighter sentence for
securities fraud the SEC was
investigating a guy named Maureen Tobin
a Los Angeles financial exec for a pump
and dump investment scheme he actually
pled guilty to conspiracy to commit
securities fraud and hasn't actually
been charged in this particular college
admissions scandal but it appears that
he snitched on Aunt Becky to get a
reduced sentence in that case but let's
talk about the Rico prosecution if you
follow ken white on Twitter and you
absolutely should he often says that it
is never Rico Rico is - Pope hat what
lupus is - dr. house it's just never
that but this time it actually is Rico
Rico or the Racketeer Influenced and
Corrupt Organizations Act is a weird
animal I've handled a few RICO claims
but always from the civil side because
I'm a civil attorney but this is
criminal Rico most people think about
Rico prosecutions as being synonymous
with the government is really serious
and is bringing down the hammer but
that's generally wrong it's also
understandable because of the context in
which Rico usually appears Rico was
initially passed in the 1970s with the
intent to pursue the Mafia the idea
behind Rico was to tie all of their
crimes together into one case which
allowed the prosecution to be able to
connect the incidents allowing for
convictions of the bosses behind all the
crimes with all of the underlings as
well it was necessary because it's
really hard to prosecute the mob
traditional tools like conspiracy
charges were hard to prove without
direct links to the upper mob bosses so
some would say that Rico is written
intentionally vaguely to capture
enterprises like the mob that would
otherwise evade prosecution to this day
when prosecutors have traditional
criminal law tools available to use they
often use those to avoid the convoluted
issues of Rico but in general a properly
stated RICO claim requires one conduct
to of an enterprise three a pattern and
four a pattern of racketeering activity
conduct here is pretty clear bribes
fraud it's all over the place the
enterprise at issue here is the key and
all the participants of that
organization a pattern under Rico only
requires two acts and here there are
many more of that and the element of
racketeering activity is extremely broad
the statute includes things like
kidnapping gambling arson robbery
bribery extortion and a list of a whole
lot of other things it's actually
impossible to have a racketeering claim
without a finding that the defendant is
guilty of another criminal violation
often this is called a Rico predicate
here the Rico predicates include mail
fraud wire fraud and money laundering
and interestingly here the ringleader
singer was a cooperating witness and
basically went through his rolodex of
co-conspirators calling up his old
acquaintance and saying hey remember
that fraud we did last year you were a
willing participant right cool cool if
the government proves up its case which
it looks like it should be able to do it
should be a pretty straightforward Rico
prosecution and a quick note about the
class-action lawsuits have been filed by
other students that didn't get in in the
wake of this Rico prosecution they're
going to fail and they're gonna fail
hard the point of a class action is to
adjudicate a bunch of very similar cases
at the same time and that just isn't the
case here first it would be nearly
impossible to prove that you were harmed
in other words that you didn't get into
college because of this other fraud that
was going on it would also be nearly
impossible to prove that you were
particularly injured in a similar way to
all the other class members since
admissions decisions are on an
individual basis and on top of that what
would your damages be so these class
action cases lack the commonality and
typicality that is necessary for a class
action case to proceed
unfortunately this Rico prosecution
couldn't have happened to a nicer person
I'm like excited to go prank with like
through the school prank but I'm also
literally never at school
that I think my class doesn't even and
maybe they forget I go there
Olivia Jade clearly got into USC on
merit now what I don't understand is why
you would spend millions of dollars
bribing your way into college especially
USC when you could you know just be a
better student for example you could
take francesco D'Alessio Skillshare
class on how to be a productive student
francesco shows you how to do all the
things that olivia jade never learned
like getting organized i don't really
know what my plan is today i had a
really late breakfast it was at like
12:30 ish planning ahead so once again i
didn't film anything today but I did get
an becoming a super student Skillshare
is an online learning community that
doesn't violate the RICO statute and has
over 20,000 classes on everything like
lifestyle design and technology the
first 500 legal eagles will get two free
months of Skillshare when you click on
the link below clicking that link really
helps out this channel the free premium
membership gives you unlimited access to
must know topics so you can improve your
skills and learn new things so don't pay
two hundred and fifty one thousand
dollars when you can pay eight dollars
per month on Skillshare hopefully I find
motivation to do it because if I don't
I'm gonna be so mad at myself do you
agree
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist of all my
other real law reviews where I will see
you in court